[Music]
thank you you're gonna love this you
guys are all gonna love this
um
as soon as virgie sees this he's gonna
know because i know he's seen it but
i don't think merch has
are you a fan of rap
occasionally are you a fan rap song
of new
woke white liberal sjw rap
that's the best rap uh no okay well let
me in just indulge me can you indulge me
land of the free home of the brave land
of the ar-15 home of kids in the grave
i've struggled to find the
okay so far what do you think honestly
honestly what are we thinking so far
he's a visionary he's a visionary right
he's a visionary
is that what this guy does
that's his thing that's honestly his
thing words keep the disposition sunny
i'm always trying to turn the unfunny
things funny but his name is jake novak
if you want to find anything else for g
just in case laughing feels wrong
hypocrisy's rife i gotta say something
cause you're all pro-life unless it's
taken by a gunman
i've already seen this and it really
hurts hey by the way you know this hurts
this hurts did you know that like i also
feel terrible when people die
no you can't you're a republican how's
that possible i i feel terrible when
people are shot and killed i don't think
so that doesn't sound right
why do they think that that comes with
like a good point they always say like
they're like no republicans are just
happy that you're dead and you're like
what no no not really i don't
in fact we actually care more than you
guys do because every time this [ __ ]
happens we go oh jesus christ they're
going to take our guns exactly you know
i've got something that i think you
might like from him okay you might be
interested in three weeks ago he posted
a video called
i want to be the next snl cast member
and it's his open audition oh come on oh
boy put it in the links put it in the
link oh oh
boy
we have to finish this first though 19
more because the hook is good you have
to get to the hook you got to the hook
tiny heartbeat stopped in the alma mater
you force kids into the world then
condemn them to slaughter we teach our
daughters how to hide when they should
be learning history then we're surprised
when it repeats itself it's no mystery
it's indifferent see them run when asked
how to combat the madness he'll care
about your rights they only care about
their status
where they can hold us packed in the
virgin you know what part of the song
i'm waiting for right
i
sent it in scotus enacted focus focus
focus while we hopelessly focus on the
joke that is trying to feel safe in this
country i love my home but i don't know
if we'll truly become free if we can't
agree uncle sam's holding a bad gun the
nation's fighting for its soul are we
sure it ever had one
children dying
oh that hurts i know right that hurts i
know right this is like he's gotta lift
the soul out bro this is like for those
of you asking for the link i'll give you
the link go ahead okay you're playing
it's not over yet you know like when you
stretch it's in the chat
you know sometimes when you stretch
and your back kind of like gets a little
cramp in it yeah because you stretch too
hard
this is like the douche
chill equivalent of that where
i got douche chill so hard i got like a
douche chill charlie horse
the nation's fighting for its soul are
we sure it ever had one
children die in the schools
he's also his own backing vocals like
michael jackson is he trying to be
michael
yes are they not trying to change the
room we're crying but we're not oh he's
doing the hooks
this makes
we the people like kid rock
sound like the [ __ ] beast of burden
by rolling stones no seriously
this is stairway to heaven i mean
this makes kid rock's song look like a
masterpiece
oof
so you said that there was uh
show links thank you
you ready
when did you know i know they they
addressed this in 21 jump street i want
to be when when like
when they were kind of talking about
like
they didn't know how to act like high
schoolers anymore because
they were like when did the nerds become
cool and it's it's infiltrated every
aspect of our society like these [ __ ]
dorks now these dorks
are now like the mainstream it's trendy
to be a dork
and i'm not talking about nerd culture
when it was like
video games
[ __ ] dorks yeah
i want to be the next snl cast member
and here's why i should be a contender
drama kids were the worst kids in my
opinion yeah in high school worse than
any other the stoners
i'll say this drama kids i didn't mind
the drama kids and i'll tell you why
because there weren't this many of them
they're all drama kids now everyone's a
drama kid so i hate them but like
there was only in my school you know you
had like you two dozen or so yeah yeah
right and they stuck to themselves
amazing didn't really bother nobody but
now everyone's a dorky drama student
be the next snl cast member and here's
why i should be a contender
there's a lot of male zoe de chanel's
out there now
and this guy's one of them
lorne michaels i'm jake novak and i know
that you're feeling the heat because
your roster lost kcal 80 mp that means
you got an open seat and i feel loud to
be feeling it cause when it comes to
comedy
uh let me try this sure uh you know
cause if you're gonna beg for a job
you're right there's a lot of seats to
fill
i'm gonna beg for jobs here are you
ready hey lorne michaels i think i
should be the next snl cast member
you're ready get ready you want to see
some of my amazing impressions
oh me sarcastic oh my god me
you can't do that that was really good
though
it was great it was a [ __ ] fantastic
convention i've never seen a better
frozen agent oh
all right how about this i got another
one
for jackie
damn man how do credit scores work
yes and
you get a white girlfriend yes
it's improv i have to yes and him yes
and
they're leslie jones is still there by
the way they're not going to need you if
you do that marsh they're calling right
now
snl is that is that them that was my
phone ringing lauren
new york area code that is what it hit
ching chong [ __ ] my new character is
that's its name
and obviously
has another what character does is
called jewish doctor it's another really
good one
i'm sorry we're gonna have to knock you
completely out in order to fill your
cavities
i'm gonna have to give you a very deep
coma drug oh [ __ ]
see weekly music videos on my jam bra
i'm a rapid rhyming hammy nerd like
lin-manuel miranda makes
sammy thought this was good also do you
just use the same beat for everything i
don't think andy sandberg appreciates
you using his name in this either i
don't think anyone appreciates this
but haven't you heard i'm more than a
rapper i'm an actor too oh he's an actor
too of course he is here's a couple of
nice guys getting their jackets after
you after you oh oh skits
skits
yeah yes
after you i hope after
after you
after you've seen that scene i mean i
meant right but i've been sitting on the
ringer in addition to the spitting i'm a
hell of a singer i could be bouncing out
on broadway but i'm running for 30 rock
so
[Music]
i can't
take this
i can't take this this is
this is levels of douche shells
i
i'm gonna have to see a doctor about
these douche shells i
i here i'll send you the link to the
video merch
if you want it thank you i'll put it in
the show chat for you it's easier for
you to get it there i know
um there you go and uh oh no remember we
said we weren't doing that anymore i
forgot
you know you really are yeah can i just
say something
you you really are just a duke to there
sometimes a forgetful friend just don't
think you're a forgetful frank yeah yeah
yeah she just doesn't think
literally obviously i just i really want
to give you the next big thing
monkey pox
you seem like somebody that would be
giving people monkey bugs
monkey pucks in a box oh my god dude
are you reading his bio
no i am reading his uh comments are they
good two weeks ago so this isn't our
people two weeks ago somebody wrote it's
honestly said that you don't have
friends in your life who care about you
enough to stop you from doing this
537 likes on that comment
uh 538
um
i wish they never removed the dislike
button
let's see here sort by
narcissists with recording equipment are
the worst thing to happen to the
internet all right well wookie in the
comments section i take that as kind of
an attack too
all of our feelings yeah
maybe maybe control your shot a little
bit maybe fix your groupings because
right now you're just buckshotting
everybody
maybe choke that shotgun yes there is a
little too much friendly fire over here
anyone do a quality of life check on
this guy yet
are people really doubting this chances
for snl after watching the current
season of fnl honestly this guy's
perfect
[Laughter]
jake please ignore the haters
comedy has died you are the murderer
[ __ ] [ __ ] haters wow that one was
yeah this guy's getting brutalized that
was [ __ ] brutal the comedy was i know
some of these people use her style be
smiley back in the day this dude would
have been shoved in a locker yikes era i
know it's one of our people how did we
go from norm mcdonald to this serious
question and danny saint of course
rich voss will be at governors in
leaventown july 8th through 9th thank
you thank you danny thank you danny i
always love a good rich voss appearing i
i just dropped one too but mine oh let's
see mine's more simple and to the point
all right we'll go to top and then we'll
go to newest and then we'll see
uh this is bad and you should feel bad
you've got to keep it simple sometimes
you nailed it yep
this was so bad it makes me want pete
davidson back i hope you're proud of
yourself
posted another song
and i posted one of his sketches
real quick i don't want to see a sketch
okay uh
the sketch okay the thanksgiving fight
yeah this is okay but real quick i got
to see his comments is there a part
where he goes children dying in the
school
i only watched it enough to make sure
that he wasn't gonna [ __ ] sing again
okay i think this one's he's doing i
think this one he's doing more calming
there's a comedy all right he's not very
honest i'll be honest between me and you
he's not very masculine
no not man jake wake up
jake wake up
oh
jake get your lazy ass out of bed and
start cleaning the apartment or i'll
publish your nudes to the internet it's
funny
happy things look at his arms
are those arms
cause is that ricky berkowick oh my god
what a little twink
giving to you too
alexa what time was the family zoom
thing happening family video call is on
your calendar for 6 p.m on thanksgiving
day
how much time percent can be at this
rate probably not enough hey girl
hey so this is a joke
fighting with my girlfriend alex on
quarantine thanksgiving what was this
posted
you're the one who actually listened to
this mouth hey by the way you don't have
to do the you're doing the toothbrush in
the mouth
no uh
talk
but you keep taking the toothbrush out
of your mouth but you're still talking
like this like i don't understand who
brushes your teeth in the kitchen
wouldn't you do it in your bathroom a
[ __ ] savage oh
alexa play my thanksgiving playlist
alexa this is christmas music i said
play my thanksgiving playlist i'm sorry
jake i can't play your thanksgiving
playlist because it doesn't have any
good songs on it
jake man jake buddy get a writer
this is bad this is rough huh
this is the so the joke is
this is going to be the joke through the
whole thing
stop
alexa stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god he is [ __ ] dying
alexa what i didn't say anything
[Music]
two-thirds of his body weight is in his
[ __ ] forehead so we're supposed to
believe he has a girlfriend
because his girlfriend is the alexa
no no i know that's the i guess the joke
of this but like any even a female alexa
i don't think he would be attracted to
not even the alexa no
no
all right enough no more terrible things
the jewish christmas song
we've played this guy before
marsh
we've played this guy before
i remember this guy 27 years ago
when we were playing christmas songs and
somebody sent this to us
i remember this guy he this guy's been
around for a while i don't recall this
let's watch the video
you should maybe play the video on the
screen
latkes frying in a pot of
[Music]
it's weird that he made this song
because i other otherwise i would have
had
no idea
that you were jewish
it's dressed up like
everybody eats
the brisket and mom's apple sauce
i can't i'm done can we i can't i'm
finished by the way how awful is manny
chabots
it's literally the worst